so last week a 25-page document written
by streamer fedmeister was leaked to
twitter
he accuses pokemane of being dishonest
about their relationship
she fired back on stream and honestly i
thought we were done with this entire
situation
but then over the weekend pokeman
dropped her own 11 page response
clapping back
[Music]
alright guys it's that time of year
again the score esports is hosting its
annual award show on december 11th
tune in live to twitch and youtube to
watch our hosts break down the biggest
moments from esports and streaming
while also handing out some pretty cool
awards and
while i have you here scroll down and
hit that subscribe button
alright so if you somehow missed the
drama between pokey and fed last week
and you want a quick recap
here it is last year fed a former member
of offline tv content house was accused
of sexual misconduct by several members
of otv
and the initial allegation came from
house member yvonne who accused fed of
getting into her bed multiple times and
touching her inappropriately
he was kicked out of offline tv he made
a quick twitter apology and then he went
dark
around the same time pokeman detailed
her negative experiences with him on
stream
then last week a 25-page response to
those allegations that he wrote but
never wanted to be made public
was leaked to twitter in it he briefly
apologizes to the members who accused
him
and spends the rest of the time talking
about his relationship with pokemane
and accusing her of not being truthful
the last thing we need to talk about
when it comes to this fed document from
last week
is who leaked it because in another
weird move
of people posting statements for other
people
on monday drama youtuber nicholas diorio
tweeted out a three-page document
supposedly written by the woman who
leaked
fed's original 25-page manifesto
whoever wrote the document says they
became friends in a private discord
server in that after the allegations
were made and he was kicked out of
offline tv
fed confided in them they write that
they helped fed edit the document and
that it was only supposed to be shared
with the people
fed hurt it was never supposed to be
made public
but then they decided to leak it because
they thought it would help
i guess quote i knew he would know it
was me
i knew he would be furious with me i
knew he would cut me off as a friend and
never speak to me again
but i also knew what i was about to do
was the truth
and that i cared more about him and his
ability to have a future
and less about him as my discord buddy i
couldn't sit by
and let him drown himself i felt he
wasn't in a healthy mindset
and was making these decisions because
of his issues
decisions i knew someday years from now
he would regret
so i leaked it end quote all of this
nonsense brings us to right now
over the weekend pokeman dropped her own
11 page response
basically clarifying everything in fed's
original 25 page response
why are these things so long pokey's
document responds to each major
allegation and fed's document
beginning with who wanted to have yvonne
fired
see in his magnum opus fett accuses
pokey of wanting to have yvonne fired
for being lazy and not working harder on
otv
content he provides a bunch of
screenshotted text messages between him
and pokey as proof
now in her document this is basically
the first allegation that she responds
to
quote i'm really disappointed that he
would try to publicly pit us against
each other
especially since he knows us personally
in the reality of the situation
on top of what he's already put yvonne
through this situation is also heavily
impacted by the fact that fed touched
yvonne inappropriately
which is something that otv members
weren't aware of until later
please keep this in mind when reading
the screenshots involving other house
members
because they didn't know and have done
everything in their power to help yvonne
since they found
out end quote this last part is
important because it provides some much
needed context that we didn't have
earlier pokey says that fed started
complaining about yvonne after he
inappropriately touched her
but before anyone else in the house knew
about it furthermore poki says that
fed's screenshotted text messages
of her complaining about yvonne are just
pokey parroting fed's complaints
because at the time that's the only
perspective she had
feds quote given the context that i now
have of what fed had
done to her of course i would never have
said those things or wanted her fired
anyone in her position would have
reacted the same way in an attempt to
avoid someone who has touched them
inappropriately
end quote pokey also alleges that fed
was complaining about yvonne to other
members of otv
and then eventually a meeting was called
to deal with this problem based on fed's
complaints
but again remember nobody else in the
house yet knew about yvonne's
allegations towards fed
she ends this section by saying her and
yvonne have talked pokey apologized for
the way it was handled
and that she's quote really grateful for
everything she's done for us
the next section breaks down her
relationship with fed and it's here
where she clarifies the timeline a
little bit
she says that her and fed grew close on
a trip to taiwan in 2018
and briefly considered dating pokey says
that this is where a lot of the flirty
text messages that fed references
came from but in may of 2018 pokey says
she told fed that she only ever wanted
to be friends and then shortly after
that is when the steve
incident happened steve was some dude
pokey was into
fed told steve him and pokey had a thing
she saw this as a massive breach of
trust
confronted him about it he apologized i
think you get the point what's
interesting
here is that pokey actually asked fed if
there was anything he didn't want her to
talk about
on stream and for whatever reason he
asked her specifically not to talk about
the steve incident
pokey describes fed as a serial flirt
and says that this type of flirty
behavior was normal for him
she even says it was normal for him to
sleep in girls rooms
and while they thought it was strange
they chalked it up to
typical fed behavior she also calls
their relationship confusing and
complicated
and says that there were times where
they unintentionally hurt each other
pokey ends the fed section of her
document with this summary
quote i hear a lot of hurt feelings in
fed's statement when it comes to our
friendship i cared about fed a lot and
wouldn't have wanted to hurt him
his feelings are valid and a good
reminder to me that what one person
thinks
may be going on in a friendship doesn't
always match up with the other person's
expectations
looking back i would have done a lot of
things differently and
know for a fact that neither of us
handled the situation perfectly
however our private conversations
heavily lacked context
and i'm not okay with how they're being
misrepresented end quote
the final section of pokey's 11-page
document deals with jody
a streamer who fed once had a shipping
relationship with and if you don't know
what shipping is jesus christ it hurts
to do this
shipping is when the audiences of two
streamers
push the narrative that those two
streamers should get together
they ship them and this often includes
coming up with
stupid-ass nicknames like fodie
fed jody you get it anyway a bunch of
different drama between
jody and pokey popped off that i'm not
going to get into here
the point is pokey's section on jody is
basically her
saying that fed allegedly manipulated
both sides according to her fed said a
bunch of negative stuff
about jodie to pokey and because of that
pokey had a negative view of jody
because remember at the time her and fed
were like best friends
pokey even provides her own
screenshotted text messages this time
around
because remember kids these days you
always need
receipts but of course there was more to
the story jody didn't actually do
anything wrong and once again
fed manipulated people's perspectives or
so pokey alleges and that's basically it
pokey's statements were much shorter
than
feds and she ends the entire thing on
this
summary quote ultimately my complicated
and volatile friendship with fed
had no part in why he was kicked out of
offline tv and such private details
never needed to be made public
it has been extremely jarring to have my
privacy violated by someone i trusted
for so
long out of respect to my friends who
are mentioned in these conversations
they were all shown the texts and were
of course given the option to decline
any conversations from being included
if any part of the conversations were
blocked i have done so to maintain
privacy for them
and will not disclose that info i hope
this context shows my side of the story
and helps put this to rest end quote now
the reaction to this
predictably has been pretty shitty a lot
of the replies have been ignorant morons
dumping on pokemane
because it's pokemane while others have
been wondering why any of this was made
public in the first place
and honestly i'm wondering the same
thing for two people who talk a lot
about wanting to keep this private not
share these intimate details
they sure are talking about this a lot
and probably one of the most
public ways possible all jokes aside i
hope fed and pokey are able to put this
[ __ ] to rest
because this is a very public and
probably very painful falling out
between two people who were at one point
really good friends and for the love of
everything [ __ ] holy on this planet
please
no more documents no more twit longers
i don't want this to be a trilogy
i gotta put some stank on this part
all right all right all right
all right all right all right
[Music]
[ __ ] me